اليابان حيث يسكن الشيطان
، إحدى أعظم الدول في التكنولوجيا والذكاء الاصطناعي
، واحدة من أقل الدول من حيث نسبة الأمية في العالم.
لكن ماذا عن الجانب المظلم في اليابان؟
نشأت وحدة سرية،
أجرت تجارب أبحاث لأسلحة بيولوجية على البشر
أثناء الحرب بين الصين واليابان
، نفذ عندها الضباط اليابانيون أفظع الجرائم
التي ارتكبت في التاريخ
أبقت أمريكا على حياة شيرو إيشي
فالانتقام منه لن يفيدهم بشيء
هذا الرجل ليس بشخص ياباني عادي
لقد كان قائد الوحدة ٧٣١
عرفت هذه الوحدة بأنها، تعمل في تنقية المياه،
في القرب من منشوريا،
لكنها في الواقع كانت تعمل في تصنيع وتطوير الأسلحة البيولوجية
ولم تكتفي بذلك فقط،
الوحدة ٧٣١
في العام١٩٣٢
تم تكليف الطبيب الجنرال الياباني شيرو إيشي
بمشروع يحد من الأوبئة في الجيش الياباني
قام شيرو إيش ببناء معسكر سجناء
في أقليم منشوريا المحتل حينها،
وأطلق على هذا  المشروع اسم
، الوحدة 731،
تظاهرت الوحدة  بأن عملها سلمي
وهي في الواقع كانت وحدة أبحاث بيولوجية متقدمة
إلى هنا يبدو الموضوع طبيعي
بدأت روائح الاستخدامات القذرة للوحدة ٧٣١
تفوح للعلن،
باستخدام السجناء الصينيين والسوفييت
كفئران تجارب لأبحاث مجنونة
وتسببت  هذه الوحدة في مقتل أكثر من 10 آلاف
من أسرى الحرب الصينيين وأسرى من شبه الجزيرة الكورية
ومنغوليا والاتحاد السوفيتي
التجارب التي قامت بها الوحدة٧٣١
تشريح أسرى الحرب أحياء دون تخدير
خوفا من أن يؤثر التخدير على دقة نتائج التجارب
تم التشريح على السجناء بعد حقنهم بأمراض مختلفة
. حيث يقوم العلماء بإجراء جراحة على السجناء
، وإزالة الأعضاء الداخلية لدراسة آثار المرض
على الجسم البشري. وأجريت هذه العمليات
على مرضى على قيد الحياة
في حين كان يعتقد أن عملية التخدير
من شأنها أن تؤثر على النتائج.
• كما أجريت عمليات تشريح على النساء الحوامل،
وانتزعت الأجنة لدراسة انتقال المرض إليها من قبل الأم
تجربة الأسلحة..
ربطت الوحدة ٧٣١ السجناء بأعمدة
على مسافات مختلفة واستخدمتهم
كأهداف لدراسة تأثير القنابل الجرثومية والكيميائية والمتفجرات.
تجارب أخرى
• علقت الوحدة بعض السجناء رأسًا على عقب
لمعرفة إلى أي مدى سيظلون يختنقون.
• حقنت الوحدة  السجناء بالهواء
لتحديد الوقت اللازم لظهور أعراض السكتة.
حرمت الوحدة السجناء من الطعام والماء لمدة من الزمن حتى الموت
لمعرفة أقصى درجة يتحملها جسم الإنسان.
بعد استسلام اليابان سارعت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
للسيطرة على تلك الأبحاث غير القابلة للتكرار
بسبب القيود الأخلاقية والقانونية للاستفادة من نتائجها
وحرمان السوفييت منها،
عمل الأمريكان بقاعدة
( الإبقاء على الثعابين حية مفيد جدا كي يستخلص الترياق منها بسهولة)
فجندوا شيرو إيشي لتطوير سلاح الحرب البيولوجية في الجيش الأمريكي
مقابل العفو عن حياته
وكانت فضيحة أخلاقية شهيرة في المجتمع الأمريكي
عندما كشفها مقال صحفي
إلا أنها مضت بعد توقيع ميثاق بين أمريكا وروسيا
يجرم استخدام وتطوير الأسلحة البيولوجية،،،
وحدة سرية يابانية خالفت الأعراف والتقاليد
، وتجردت من الإنسانية، ارتكبت أبشع الجرائم الوحشية،
في دولة باتت تعرف بالحضارة والتقدم والمدنية،،
الوحدة٧٣١ ما لم تعرفه عن اليابان،،،،